it's a game and i just made it up for
you guys it's called hot or not
okay and it's gonna be like boys and pop
culture trends okay so this year's
people magazine's sexiest man alive is
none other than mr brad pitt so
like maya anna thoughts hot or not
hot
like
he's like so hot
it burns
yeah
then there's this like really cool trend
um it's the nokia 3310 cell phone
yeah my brother got one and my mom won't
give me one but it's it's hot is he
older than you he's one grade older he's
in eighth grade have you said like when
i become his age can i get one yeah she
said when you get a little more mature
which is such a like
thing to say like i am mature like what
the hell you're the most mature person
i've ever met i know
so anyway so we are too because like
when somebody tells me to do something i
almost like feel like doing the exact
topic yeah yeah i'm like oh you want me
to be mature
um
okay everybody loves victoria's secrets
yes um and i felt like really good about
myself when i look at all the victoria's
secret stuff i definitely am like oh
yeah i can fit into there
yeah me too love spell by victoria's
secret is that hot or not
um
what is love spell it's the smell that
smells like
tangerine tangy thingy or whatever wow i
haven't been allowed meredith wears all
the time like oh
did she get boys yeah
well maybe then we should buy a bottle
yeah let's say hot
it's a little strong
yeah i think we need to go shopping
after that yeah okay
amazing bricks your way yeah what are
you doing after this
we could go to the mall or i don't know
or not if you're busy it's fine i'm
sorry
like like hot dog on a stick yeah i'll
eat a hot dog
do okay think that like frosted tips on
a boy are hot or not
hot
not
okay yeah not not oh my god i am totally
with my eye i
like
i'm like what did you do to yourself you
look like a porcupine with like like ice
on top like it's weird i'm like oh god
you're a human cupcake why all the
frosting yeah
no i know that is what i think yeah and
that is why
i said the wrong word by mistake okay
[Laughter]
you know when you put like juicy tubes
like and lip gloss and lip smackers and
all those things on your lips and
sometimes i wonder like
like
is a boy gonna look at my
mouth and see all that like slicky sexy
wetness and just be like i gotta have it
juicy tubes hot or not
um
[Music]
hot yeah
whatever maya thinks hot
i think it's hot
i do like who doesn't look at a girl
with like really glossy lips and not
just big like
yeah
i think i think we should you know what
we can get some when we go to the mall
perfect and test it out and then like
walk around with like lots of lip gloss
and just see like if it's like fly paper
to the boys yeah and because we could
use the samples
yeah good idea so we don't have to buy
they're smart not even handle it
um but also we could like come back here
after the mall and and watch like bring
it on are you guys into that movie i
we've watched it like 10 times yeah
[Applause]
oh my god
[Music]
you